>> Will Sentance: Chúng tôi đã có hai chức năng mặt tiền mạnh mẽ của chúng tôi, trời ơi,
chúng có đáng chú ý không?
Và nếu bạn nhớ,
Tôi chỉ muốn hỏi câu hỏi mà chúng tôi đã hỏi ngay trước giờ giải lao chỉ một lần nữa.
Đó là, làm rõ của chúng tôi là gì?
Và tôi nghĩ là, có ai có thể nhớ một trong những câu hỏi tôi đã hỏi không?
Bạn hỏi có phải là Todd không?
Chờ đã, những gì sẽ?
Vâng, hãy tiếp tục.
>> Người nói 2: Tôi đoán khi nào điều đó được đưa vào ngăn xếp cuộc gọi?
>> Will Sentance: Vâng, khi nào thì chức năng đó bị trì hoãn, trì hoãn bởi
được đính kèm với đối tượng hứa hẹn trên mảng thực hiện?
Khi nào thì chức năng đó, với điều kiện là nó được tự động kích hoạt để chạy?
Nó có trở nên tuyệt vời không?
Ý tôi là nó trong JavaScript, vậy nó có đi thẳng vào ngăn xếp cuộc gọi không?
Không điên để nghĩ, tốt,
chúng tôi sẽ cần hiểu các quy tắc mà lời hứa của chúng tôi được trì hoãn
chức năng quay trở lại JavaScript để được thực thi.
Bạn biết không, hãy quay trở lại ngăn xếp cuộc gọi nó bằng JavaScript.
Quay lại ngăn xếp cuộc gọi để được thực hiện.
Chúng ta sẽ thấy điều đó ở đây.
Hãy nhanh chóng nhắc lại ở đây phương pháp và chức năng then, nó làm gì
nói, sau đó là phương thức và chức năng để gọi, vâng, phương thức then và
chức năng gọi và hoàn thành bất kỳ mã nào chúng tôi muốn chạy sẽ trả về dữ liệu.
Dữ liệu phản hồi phải được thêm vào đối tượng lời hứa
đã thêm bằng cách sử dụng phương thức then vào thuộc tính ẩn trên mảng thực hiện.
Các đối tượng Promise sẽ tự động kích hoạt hàm được đính kèm trong mảng đó để chạy
với đầu vào là dữ liệu phản hồi từ tính năng trình duyệt web từ Twitter.
Được rồi, chúng ta đi thôi.
Hãy xem, đây là mã phức tạp nhất mà chúng ta sẽ thấy ngày hôm nay.
Chúng ta sẽ xem chiều nay nhưng đây là một trong những chức năng của tôi ở đây
để tôi thử và thu nhỏ mã và chỉ đi đến phần lõi.
Nhưng chúng ta cần ba ở đây để xem các quy tắc mà
mã hoãn lại không đồng bộ sẽ được chạy.
Và nhân tiện, tôi sẽ chốt lại ở cuối từ không đồng bộ nghĩa là gì.
Tôi sẽ nói ngay bây giờ.
Nó có nghĩa là làm mã không theo thứ tự từ khi bạn nhìn thấy nó,
từ khi nó được cho là đã được thực hiện.
Vì vậy, khi chúng ta thấy mã JavaScript bình thường, nếu một dòng cho biết mã đó,
Tôi làm điều đó ngay sau đó.
Nếu dòng nói làm mã, tôi làm ngay lúc đó.
Không đồng bộ nói không, không,
không, JavaScript sẽ xử lý khi chức năng đó hoạt động trở lại.
Và nó sẽ không theo thứ tự khi bạn kích hoạt tính năng trình duyệt
mà bắt đầu công việc của nó.
Và chức năng liên quan sẽ hoạt động trở lại khi
công việc nền được thực hiện.
Chúng tôi không còn có mã của chúng tôi nữa, chúng tôi không thể để lại dòng mã này cho đến khi chúng tôi hoàn thành
nó cho đến khi chúng tôi chuyển sang dòng tiếp theo.
Bây giờ chúng ta thực sự có thể có mã sẽ được chạy sau
tất cả mã thông thường của chúng tôi được chạy.
Được rồi, vậy chúng ta sẽ xem tất cả những điều đó diễn ra như thế nào ở đây từng dòng một.
Chúng tôi đã có ES5 truyền thống của chúng tôi và thời gian đặt trước đó với một chức năng.
Nó sẽ được ném xuống trình duyệt web.
Chúng tôi đã có cuộc gọi tìm nạp của chúng tôi với hai ngạnh.
Với mặt này, với mã này và sơ đồ này,
chúng ta sẽ thấy toàn bộ bản đồ về sự không đồng bộ trong JavaScript.
Được rồi, chúng ta bắt đầu, các bạn.
Chúng tôi gần như đang ở rào cản cuối cùng.
Không hẳn.
Bắt đầu.
Dòng một, vào bộ nhớ toàn cầu của chúng ta, chúng ta sẽ lưu trữ những gì, bạn tôi, Matt?
>> Loa 2: Màn hình hiển thị chức năng.
>> Will Sentance: Tuyệt vời, chức năng >> Will Sentance: Hiển thị, nó đây.
Được lưu vào bộ nhớ chung.
Cảm ơn Matt.
Bây giờ đến dòng tiếp theo của Tod.
>> Loa 2: Hàm in lời chào.
>> Will Sentance: In xin chào.
Được lưu trữ trong bộ nhớ chung cũng như được khai báo và lưu trữ trong bộ nhớ.
Dòng tiếp theo, Ryan, chúng ta nên làm gì là an toàn?
Xóa khối chức năng trong 300 mili giây hoặc
300 mili giây một khối trong 30 mili giây.
Tôi muốn cắt những bit này trong hơn 300 mili giây.
Đây rồi.
Đó là một khối mới trong 300 mili giây.
Và bây giờ mọi thứ trở nên thú vị.
Bây giờ chúng ta đến thời gian chờ đã định.
Nó có làm bất cứ điều gì thú vị trong JavaScript không, mọi người?
>> Người nói 2: Không.
>> Will Sentance: Không, không phải, đây là một trong những vấn đề duy nhất.
Thực ra, hãy đưa trình duyệt web của chúng ta lên đây, ngay tại đây.
Trình duyệt web.
Chúng tôi đã có, màu trắng là công cụ và tính năng JavaScript.
Và sau đó bạn đã đến đây, chúng tôi có các yêu cầu mạng
là một trong những tính năng của trình duyệt web được xây dựng bằng C ++, chắc chắn không phải trong JavaScript.
Và nó được điều khiển từ bên trong JavaScript bởi chức năng mặt tiền tìm nạp tuyệt vời này.
Sau đó, chúng tôi đã có bảng điều khiển.
Chúng tôi cũng có bộ đếm thời gian, một tính năng của web
trình duyệt được kiểm soát bởi thời gian chờ đã đặt.
Nhưng có rất nhiều thứ mà chúng ta biết.
Được rồi, mọi thứ bên dưới đây sẽ diễn ra
không phải là JavaScript mà là các tính năng của trình duyệt web của chúng tôi.
Tôi đã quên điều gì khác từ nền tảng chính của chúng tôi?
Dan, tôi đang quên điều gì từ loại nền tảng Java chính của mình?
My- >> Loa 2: Ngăn xếp yêu thích của tôi.
>> Will Sentance: Vâng, không cảm thấy ngăn xếp rất thú vị.
Chính xác, nó đây.
Đây rồi. Và chúng tôi đang thực thi mã trên toàn cầu.
Vì vậy, nó đó.
Chà, không phải bao mát.
Được rồi, trong quá trình thực thi JavaScript, chúng tôi đã thực hiện chúng tôi đã làm
hiển thị khối in hello trong 300 mili giây để tiết kiệm bộ nhớ chung.
Bây giờ chúng ta đánh ổn, hãy giơ tay lên nếu bạn muốn là người nói bằng lời
thông qua, Ethan đã là chuyên gia của chúng tôi về vấn đề này, có lẽ chúng tôi sẽ chọn Ethan.
Điều đó thành lời thông qua điều này đầu tiên
chức năng mặt tiền đặt thời gian ra.
Hãy giơ tay lên nếu bạn muốn là người huy động thông qua việc này,
Vì tôi không nhìn xung quanh, tôi thực sự không thể biết được.
Vì vậy, nhưng tôi không thể thấy Matt ở đó.
Matt, nói cho tôi biết chuyện gì đang xảy ra.
Bất cứ ai đã giơ tay tuyệt vời, cảm ơn bạn.
Nhưng là người duy nhất mà cô ấy cảm thấy tức điên.
Cho tôi quay lưng lại.
Vậy đúng rồi, Matt, đặt thời gian chờ, hậu quả của nó là ở đâu?
>> Người thuyết trình 2: Sẽ chuyển sang tính năng trình duyệt web, tính năng hẹn giờ.
>> Will Sentance: Tuyệt vời, tuyệt vời.
Tính năng trình duyệt web.
>> Người nói 2: Nó sẽ gửi cho nó thời lượng, giá trị bằng không.
>> Will Sentance: Rất hay.
>> Loa 2: Và chức năng chạy print hello.
>> Will Sentance: Được rồi, điều đó thật xuất sắc.
Điều đó đã được truyền đạt rất tốt, cảm ơn bạn.
Vâng chính xác.
Không có mili giây của chúng tôi.
Và có chức năng của chúng tôi để chạy khi hoàn thành việc đó.
Ngày nay, hãy nói chính xác hơn, chức năng của chúng tôi để thêm vào,
>> Loa 2: Ngăn xếp cuộc gọi.
>> Will Sentance: Ngăn xếp cuộc gọi >> Người thuyết trình 2: Hàng đợi gọi lại
>> Will Sentance: Hàng đợi gọi lại lên đến
chính xác là hàng đợi gọi lại khi hoàn thành không mili giây.
Vì vậy, hãy thiết lập một bộ đếm thời gian.
Đây rồi.
Bộ hẹn giờ, không mili giây.
Hoàn thành ở 0 mili giây mọi người.
>> Người nói 2: Đúng.
>> Will Sentance: Vâng, chính xác, yeah.
Sau khi hoàn thành, những gì chúng ta muốn chạy?
Chúng ta muốn lấy lại JavaScript điều gì, Todd?
>> Diễn giả 2: In chào.
>> Will Sentance: In xin chào, chính xác là 0 mili giây là hoàn thành
như tất cả các bạn đã nói?
Bạn đặt cược đó là.
Nó đã hoàn tất, hẹn giờ khi hoàn thành, chúng tôi sẽ gọi
In, họ chỉ nên bảo họ đi từ phía trước của quái vật
nếu tôi hiện đang di chuyển trên màn hình phía trước của nó.
Không có mát mẻ.
Đây rồi.
in xin chào.
sẽ diễn ra vào thời điểm đó nhưng chúng ta hãy đưa ra ngay bây giờ.
Hãy đưa nó lên ngay bây giờ.
Mát mẻ.
>> Di chúc: Que.
Đây rồi, gọi lại hàng đợi.
Vì vậy, ở 0 mili giây, nó đã hoàn tất.
Jeff, điều gì sẽ xảy ra với hàm in hello trên ngăn xếp cuộc gọi?
>> [KHÔNG NGHE ĐƯỢC] >> Will Sentance: Không, hàng đợi gọi lại.
Jeff xuất sắc.
Ở 0 mili giây.
Chính xác.
Mili giây.
Chúng tôi sẽ có bản in xin chào.
Tôi chắc rằng nó sẽ chạy gần như ngay lập tức, phải không?
Vâng.
Gửi cho tôi tất cả những thứ tuyệt vời đó sớm.
Chúng tôi nhận được rất nghiêm túc và háo hức ở đây.
Nó đã sẵn sàng để được nhân hóa.
Chức năng rất vui mừng.
Tôi gần như không thể chờ đợi.
Sẵn sàng bắt đầu cuộc gọi.
Công việc đặt thời gian chờ được thực hiện khi thiết lập bộ hẹn giờ và thời gian nền công việc của anh ấy
được thực hiện bởi vì nó đặt chức năng thấp của máy in trong hàng đợi gọi lại.
Tuyệt vời hét lên với tất cả những người bằng lời nói rất hay.
Bây giờ chúng ta tiếp tục với The Hardhee
khu vực chúng tôi sẽ tiếp tục với tốc độ một phần nghìn giây.
Và cố gắng giữ nó càng gọn gàng càng tốt.
Cày vào đó một phần nghìn giây.
Ethan bên tay trái, chúng ta đang làm gì ở dòng tiếp theo, bên tay trái?
>> Diễn giả 2: Khai báo dữ liệu tương lai const.
>> Will Sentance: futureData, nó đây,
dữ liệu tương lai.
Nó là một mặt tiền có hai hướng.
Không, không phải, nó sẽ có kết quả của cuộc gọi tìm nạp của chúng tôi,
hệ quả JavaScript của nó.
Là giá trị của dữ liệu trong tương lai, bởi vì lệnh gọi tìm nạp đó, hàm mặt tiền tìm nạp đó,
hàm mặt tiền tìm nạp đó là một hàm mặt tiền hai hướng.
Xem yêu cầu mạng trong trình duyệt web và nội dung bằng JavaScript.
Hãy xem xét nó trong hệ quả JavaScript.
Vì vậy, chúng tôi sẽ gọi tìm nạp.
Nó đây, với chỉ một chuỗi của chúng ta, nhân tiện JavaScript chỉ là một chuỗi.
Có ai đã lấy dữ liệu của anh ấy xuống không
trình duyệt mà nó trở nên có ý nghĩa hơn?
Chính xác thì nó là gì?
Twitter twitter.com.
Chúng tôi sẽ rút ngắn nó một chút.
Vâng, chúng ta bắt đầu.
Được rồi, đó là hệ quả của JavaScript, Dan có phải là hệ quả JavaScript của anh ấy không?
Nó tạo ra một lời hứa mới.
Vâng, chính xác trả lại ngay lập tức, do đó được lưu trữ ở bên trái
bên tay trong khoảnh khắc một phần nghìn giây này một đối tượng, đối tượng đặc biệt.
Đối tượng Promise và đối tượng đó sẽ được lưu trữ ở đây trong dữ liệu trong tương lai.
Và là gì >> Will Sentance: Tự động
tài sản trên đó, Dan?
>> Người thuyết trình 2: Giá trị của nó và >> Lời gửi gắm: Chưa hoàn thành nghĩa là,
đó là mảng của chính xác một mảng ngay bây giờ là một mảng trống nhưng
nó sẽ là một mảng hàm được sinh ra từ những điều đã nói.
Đây rồi.
Họ đi đến mảng và họ đánh giá tài sản và chúng ta đừng quên.
Thuộc tính giá trị đó ngay sau khi được cập nhật, ngay lập tức
sẽ kích hoạt chức năng được lưu trữ trong mảng đó tự động chạy.
Rất tốt, đó là bởi vì nếu chúng ta, và nhân tiện.
Tài sản giá trị này ở đây tôi có cảm giác sẽ được kết nối mật thiết
với hệ quả khác, ngạnh khác
từ tìm nạp đang nói chuyện với mạng trong trình duyệt web.
Và ngay sau khi hoàn tất, giá trị đó sẽ trả về đối tượng phản hồi như
Kayla đã nói trước đó, sẽ điền vào thuộc tính giá trị đó
Quay lại JavaScript sẽ tự động kích hoạt bất kỳ chức năng nào trong
mảng đó với giá trị đó làm đầu vào của hàm đó hoặc các hàm đó.
Được rồi, hoàn hảo.
Bây giờ chúng ta hãy giao cho người khác, Chúa ơi, bây giờ hãy xử lý các ngạnh khác của việc tìm nạp.
Bút màu xanh, đó là thứ của trình duyệt web.
>> Will Sentance: Vì vậy, chỉ cần nhắc chúng tôi, Brayden, web là gì
tính năng trình duyệt được bật.
>> Người thuyết trình 2: Yêu cầu mạng.
>> Will Sentance: Yêu cầu mạng.
Làm tốt chính xác.
Yêu cầu mạng.
Đây rồi.
xuống nó đến, xuống nó là trình duyệt web,
đây chúng ta bắt đầu, >> Will Sentance: Tư thế tốt nhất của tôi,
yêu cầu mạng.
Được rồi, chúng ta bắt đầu.
Nó sẽ không phải là một cuộc nói chuyện vượt qua hội trường.
Đây rồi.
Bây giờ, chúng tôi yêu cầu, chúng tôi cần thông tin gì, Adam, ở phía sau?
Chúng tôi cần thông tin gì cho yêu cầu mạng đó?
>> Người nói 2: Địa chỉ.
>> Will Sentance: Đúng vậy, chúng tôi có hai phần quan tâm.
Có ai muốn nói cho tôi biết không, Brayden?
>> Diễn giả 2: Miền. >> Will Sentance: Tên miền
và- >> Người thuyết trình 2: Thư mục.
>> Will Sentance: Vâng, chính xác là phần khác của,
phần chúng tôi muốn lấy dữ liệu.
Vì vậy, tên miền là Twitter .com, đường dẫn là / will / 1 và nó được mặc định để lấy.
Và cứ khoảng 1 mili giây,
chúng tôi bắt đầu đi đến, chúng tôi sẽ làm điều này ở đâu?
Có lẽ Hmm, chúng tôi nghĩ bất kỳ điều gì tôi đoán là khối lập phương rất nhỏ.
Đến trụ sở chính của Twitter, trụ sở chính của Twitter, hãy nhìn về phía xa.
Đây rồi, với tin nhắn nói lời chào, tôi cần một số tweet mới,
vì vậy những tweet đó.
Và chúng tôi gửi đi khoảng cách đó.
Không mili giây.
Xinh đẹp.
Đây rồi.
Và nó có hoàn chỉnh ở điểm đó không?
Chúng ta có dữ liệu trở lại không, Dan?
Không, chúng tôi biết chúng tôi không muốn đặt chính xác nó ở đó.
Nhưng khi nó hoàn thành, mụn cóc Hãy giơ tay lên.
Bạn muốn cho tôi biết điều gì sẽ xảy ra.
Quay lại JavaScript, quá trình hoàn thành của chúng ta trong JavaScript là gì?
Anh ấy sẽ cho bạn xem một chiếc bánh pizza.
Đối tượng trả về được nhập vào thuộc tính giá trị của dữ liệu của bạn.
Rất rất tốt.
Chúng tôi sẽ giữ cho nó đơn giản và chỉ nói một chuỗi, chính tweet thực tế, nhưng
Vâng chính xác.
Điều đó sẽ tiếp tục và điền vào Bởi vì
dữ liệu tương lai là nơi chúng tôi lưu trữ hệ quả khác của việc tìm nạp mát mẻ.
Vấn đề có ảnh hưởng trong JavaScript cho phép chúng tôi theo dõi
nhất quán với những gì chúng tôi đang làm trong nền.
Tôi thích điều đó.
Nhìn vào sự nhất quán đó, đang làm gì đó trong nền.
Có một đối tượng hứa hẹn tốt đẹp ở phía trước,
trong JavaScript để theo dõi nó.
Bạn biết không, nó sẽ được cập nhật thuộc tính giá trị của nó khi nền
công việc hoàn thành, như Peter đã nói.
Vì vậy, dữ liệu trong tương lai, giá trị của bạn
sẽ là bất cứ thứ gì quay trở lại từ công việc nền, nhưng
công việc nền ở một phần nghìn giây vẫn chưa được thực hiện.
Và hãy tưởng tượng nếu chúng ta phải đợi nó ở phía trước trong JavaScript, hoặc
chúng tôi sẽ ngồi đó một lúc, có thể là 70 mili giây.
Và ngôn ngữ của chúng ta sẽ rất thực dụng, nhưng thay vào đó.
Nhân tiện, làm tốt lắm mọi người, chúng tôi gần như đã hoàn thành tương đối tất cả nội dung tìm nạp,
thoải mái.